[Music]
so john let me ask you something
i'm thinking about that last call um
the guy who's uh wanted to buy a tesla
but i mean i've talked to people i i
remember i had a
guy that um he had this classic oh man
it was like late 60s truck and it was
perfect
antique truck
and he was a truck driver and he drove
over the road five days a week and so he
would drive his old truck
to the uh terminal
get in the 18-wheeler drive all week and
then drive his old truck home
he was in it twice a week
and he was two miles to work
so i'd go over there one day
and i had always loved this i lusted
after this old truck it was beautiful it
was gone
he had traded it for a brand new 30
thousand dollar
ford pickup
and i'm like dude
why did you buy any finance that of
course i'm ready to kill him like what
why why did you buy a 30 000 pickup
gas mileage was killing me
four miles a week
two over
two back
for a truck payment anyway and he traded
it for
i mean there's no
possible
mathematical equation you know but it
didn't weird how uh you know we we in
sales we used to say people buy
emotionally and they uh
they justify intellectually so
there's that wasn't a fear-based thing
that guy was not in a panic he was not
having the world's coming to an end and
you're not gonna be able to get a tesla
thing he had not worked himself up into
a watching too much of cnn and he's lost
his dadgum mind or something it was not
that he just got
truck fever he just got a jones for it
he saw something that he wanted and he
backfilled an argument he went searching
for an argument that validated his point
he found one and it didn't
but but in his head all he was looking
for is that's different than the flight
or flight thing shutting down your
critical thinking skills no that's
that's when you go searching for
a
a
a problem that backs up your answer
i need a new truck it's like jeopardy
yeah i mean i need to state the question
yeah i like that that's the answer to
that i already know the answer and i got
to state the question yeah so when we go
looking for things in the world as a
great famous quote there um whenever you
go looking for the world you will surely
find it
and so we do that with people we don't
like we do that with people we're angry
with we do that with people that we love
right
people stay in toxic relationships
because i
i'm just going to only focus on the good
stuff and you know you'll talk to them
and they'll say well yeah he's only
cheated on me four times and he doesn't
doesn't hit me anymore
and your mouth's dropping open but i'm
i've decided i'm only gonna look for
this i'm not gonna look at the full
picture same with i want a new truck i
just look at that brand new truck
i can't afford that new truck and then
you start thinking what about this truck
do i not like this gas mileage is kill
and now i've painted a picture that's
going to backfill the thing the outcome
that i want right yeah but that's we do
it all the time and that guy might have
done that instead of panic do you think
the tesla guy
potentially usually when somebody comes
home and starts laying out a case i
really like this tesla i think it's
really cool and so now i'm going to
backfill the answer
and go well the world's coming to an end
you're not going to get tesla because
the lithium and the batteries there's a
possibility you know the the slave labor
children aren't able to get enough
lithium out of the mines and so we're
not gonna be able to have batteries
there's a possibility
more realistically though somebody's
done they start beautiful minding it and
they will look at this data point and
this data point and that one will string
them together and create a picture
that's not true
but that feels right and it justifies
this panicked response we gotta do
something right now yeah
and then you have this poor wife who's
just going to school you're working full
time the guy in the movie with a
beautiful mind's mind was not that
beautiful no that's the irony that's
right
he was he was crazier than a bane he's
just he's struggling man but you start
pulling together disparate data points
to paint up whatever picture you want
right
and that's big turn off the electronics
sometimes just stop yeah well and
it it does it it is a little bit of
affluenza
the the flu-like symptoms of affluence
ah yeah and so it's this thing if you
get the fever
i got a fever for a tesla
i mean you know how fast those things go
0-60 yeah well but but you know there's
battery shortage so you see the stuff
that's happening in the world and then
you just get stupid right and and you
just you
every one of us do i catch myself doing
it yeah um
at different times in my life but um
it's just an interesting dichotomy to me
because personal finance is 80 behavior
people it's only 20 percent had
knowledge i did it with you so you have
to learn to deal with the idiot in your
mirror to ever have any freaking money i
did it with a guitar recently i've a
guitar i've coveted for years somebody i
work with cody back here
says oh man i was about to sell mine
i said well of course i got to see it so
he brings it up to the office and where
me and james have a cool little band and
we're and now you're really coveting and
you've gone you've gone full into
biblical covenant plays better than i
could have imagined oh yeah and i'm
thinking
why do i need another guitar to cost
this much
for once a year when i actually pull it
all out and play
and how am i you know what i mean so it
just begot i i began to backfill i can
create an argument for this and at the
end of the day i have no need for this
at all none zero
none
none you walked away walked away well
james has it now
i sold it to james yeah so i can buy it
any time
i haven't bought it yet either yeah
but yeah it's it's we do it all the time
and that's when well the the thing about
affluenza is is that um
the more inputs you have
uh on your computer
more hours you spend on your computer
the more hours you spend in front of any
screen television or otherwise the more
advertising that happens
and you're getting about four thousand
to six thousand ads a day wow if you are
using a if you're a typical consumer of
television and computer time and if you
add to that only hanging out with people
who
think like you and won't or at least
don't love you enough to go that's the
stupidest thing i ever heard
if you don't have those people in your
life you just have a bunch of yes people
around you yeah bro people in your life
then you're just gonna continue to
reinforce what happens right before you
do something really stupid yeah yeah
yeah bro so it's it's it's also language
yeah it's just being able to back out of
that that's why i it's something so
simple like having a budget
yeah it just says yeah it's something
that are facts that hold you accountable
accountable that's right and it doesn't
have to be some friend that knocks
upside the head but it wouldn't hurt
yeah but but the you got a little piece
of paper here that says when my brain
was working this is what we agree this
is what we agreed on right oh and it's
if it doesn't align with that then
possibly i need to back up my brain
might not be working is there a gap
between impulse and action and that's
what a budget gives you that's what a
friend gives you that's what a good
spouse gives you that's what taking a
walk around the block gets you is there
a space between you know wait overnight
or in in that guy's case a minute ago
he's got a good wife yeah who's saying
ah did you lose your mind by the way we
just spent all this what you just
thought would you go find that brain you
left it outside on the sidewalk i think
and uh you got to call each other out on
it and you go that just doesn't make
sense and if you know yourself like i
know myself i put i put barriers between
me and right yeah
and
again
we're sitting here saying that we have
both faced exactly the same stuff
but i got to tell you folks
if you the less
television and computer time you have
the less financial stupidity will be in
your life yeah because you're not
getting impacted with as much
advertising it's a pretty simple
equation